اهلا بكم الى موجز اللي اهم الانباء عقدت
نائبه الرئيس الامريكي كمالا هارس اجتماعا
طارقا مع اليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه وكندا
واستراليا ونيوزيلندا على اهم شيء قمه
ايباد للبحث في اطلاق كوريا الشماليه
صاروخا بعيد المدى خلال الاجتماع قالت
ان اودعت هاريس كوريا الشماليه الى وقف
استفزازاتها كما قال رئيس الوزراء
الياباني ان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت اكثر من
50 صاروخا وقال رئيس الوزراء الكندي ان
بلاده تقف الى جانب حلفائها في المنطقه
حتى تضمن وقف كوريا الشماليه عمليتها
الاستفزازيه
البيت الابيض قال انه يدين بقوه اطلاق
كوريا الشماليه صاروخا بعيد المدى واضاف
ان واشنطن ستتخذ كافه الاجراءات لضمني امن
اليابان وكوريا الجنبيه هذا وقال الجيش
الكوري الجنوبي ان كوريا الشماليه اطلقت
صاروخا يشتبه في انه باليسيون عابر من
القارات قال وزير الدفاع الياباني ان مد
الصاروخ كان كافيا للوصول الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من جانبه قال رئيس
الوزراء الياباني
ان الصاروخ الكوريه الشماليه
سقط في المياه الاقتصاديه اليابانيه
اعلن رئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان تمديدا
اتفاقي تصدير الحبوب ل 120 يوما اعتبارا
من التاسعه عشر من الشهر الجاري اوضح ان
الاتفاقه اتاح توفير اكثر من 11 مليون طلا
من الحبوب والمواد الغذائيه للمحتاجين في
العالم
بدورها رحبت الامم المتحده بتمديد الاتفاق
وقال الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوترش من الاتفاق ضروري لتفادي ازمه غذاء
عالميه
في موسكو اعلنا الكرملين انه لا حديث عن
تمديد صفقه الحبوب لاجل غير مسمى واضاف ان
موسكو حصلت على ضمانات من الامم المتحده
بشان رفع القيود عن الصادرات الروسيه في
اطار الصفقه الحبوب
اعتمد مجلس محافظ الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه
الذريه قرارا يدعو ايران الى التعاون بشكل
عاجل مع تحقيق الوكاله بشان اثاره
يورانيوم في ثلاثه مواقع غير معلنه بدورها
اصدرت بريطانيا وفرنسا والمانيا بيننا
ثلاثيا وصفت فيه الانشطه الايرانيه
بالتصعيد النوويه غير المسبوق المقابله
اتهم مدير الوكاله الايرانيه للطاقه
الذريه محمد اسلامي الدول الغربيه بممارسه
ضغوط سياسيه على بلاده وقال اننا الوثائق
التي قدمت للوكاله غير حقيقيه
على النت وزاره الداخليه في قطاع غزه
وفاته جميع من كانوا في المبنى السكني
الذي اتهمته النيران في مخيم جباليا
الشماليه القطاع وقل المتحدث باسم الوزاره
ان تحقيقات الاوليه في الحدث اشارات الى
وجود كميات كبيره من البنزين داخل المبنى
مما اجج نيران وقال الدفاع المدني ان
الطواقيمه انتشلت احدى عشرين الجثه قضت في
الحريق
الوطنيه في القطاع الاضراب الشامل اليوم
الجمعه حدادا على الضحيه
حكم هذا الموجز شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]